but i was going to say one of the things
i've been able to do in my career such
as it is
often is choose because i've not been
broke
and that's a huge big deal and one of
the reasons that happened
is that very early on i started doing
voice overs i had a voice over agent i
was doing commercials it meant when i
was offered jobs
where i thought the part was not
small but
bad i didn't do them so some of the
praise i've got from your mum for
instance
there is because i was free enough not
doing other shitty things to go
that is a brilliant script and that is a
brilliant part
and i was lucky enough to get offered it
but if you're not able
to pick and choose the really good parts
and you're not like enough to come your
way
it doesn't matter how good an act you
are you'll never have a break
wow you know so it's i was lucky i i was
after the patriot when i came to work
with you
i was offered every one-dimensional bad
guy in hollywood opposite all of the
kind of big alpha male guys because i've
just been opposite velocity
roles were really well written past
right
that you rejected what roles after that
that came to you any big ones that you
rejected after the patriot
oh yeah you can't say things like that
yeah yeah the other actors did them i'm
a bit dumb
i should have done them for the money
and to cement my status
instead i went to the play about the
northern irish peace process i played a
in a third bleed drag queen i did a
bunch of indie things
i probably should have listened to my
age and gone just do three or four of
these things and i was going well
they're done
the part in the patriot was a
brilliantly complicated wonderful guy
and the story
and mel gibson and roland gave him
status i came on screen and shot a bunch
of kids i
burned a church but lots of the other
villains i was offered were so
wafer thin i would have looked bad in it
and i wouldn't get any other work
in retrospect it was dumb i should have
taken
jobs made money and no one's you know
playing three-dimensional career chess
i could've done some good stuff
afterwards but i was too so
proud and picky i wanted only to do
things i thought were great
and that's really been consistently the
story of most of what i've do every now
and again i just do a piece of
because it's a good check or it's a nice
holiday but
mostly i try and curate for my own ego
and pride
if i can't be the most famous or richest
person in the world i can at least look
back at the work i've done
and gone that's good stuff and that's
interesting and those are interesting
parts
and when the credits run people can have
a conversation